[Music]
recently apple announced these macbook
pros with some bold claims
gets up to 21 hours of video playback
which is 10 additional hours and the
longest battery life ever on a mac
notebook are you sure about that apple
come on someone had to test it so i set
up this new 16-inch macbook pro which
has an m1 max chip to play this video
clip for 21 hours
and the 16-inch model gets up to 21
hours of video playback and i did
exactly what apple said wi-fi off and
brightness at 8 clicks from the bottom
and i am plugged
for a long time
okay not quite 21 hours but wow that's
long enough to last you a 15 hour flight
from new york to shanghai and then some
although if you were planning to use
wi-fi and chat and surf the web then
you'd be looking at more of an
eight-hour flight from new york to
munich so why did i do all this well
because the promise of a truly all-day
laptop is here and you don't even need
bigger batteries to do it all the real
savings comes from apple's shift from
intel chips to its own m1 pro and m1 max
chips
so when apple said
and the longest battery life ever on a
mac notebook there is only one thing to
do
testing these are crooked aren't they
okay before i get into those test
results let's talk about these which
have the dream laptop design
at least in comparison to the old
macbook pros
there is a full-size sd card slot and an
hdmi port sure the sd card still sticks
out but i'll take it
there's a row of real function keys rip
touch bar
and yes the magsafe charger is back you
can still charge via these usb-c ports
too the xcr screens are bright and
beautiful and the size of the screens
are really the main thing that separates
these two oh and price the 14 inch
starts at 2 000 and the 16 at 2500
really pricey
i could live without this notch around
the webcam though
to make the bezels around the screen
smaller they had to fit the 1080p webcam
in some place
don't get me wrong the camera quality is
way better than the previous laptops but
still no iphone selfie camera the bigger
leaps though are inside these machines
with apple's own m1 pro and m1 max chips
the chips are incredibly fast i couldn't
get these laptops to slow down even when
multitasking things like video editing
gaming and more and when i asked apple's
tom bogger what the biggest improvement
in going from intel to apple was he said
i sum it up in a very simple term of
performance per watt
uh it's it's game-changing what does
that even mean
allow me to explain with this stuff
let's say this container of powerade is
well power or watts and well i need
performance cheers sipping the watts for
power and then using the power to do
things powered up
intel chips based on x86 architecture
have good performance but are more power
thirsty
so to do this high performance i've got
to chug more power
intel processor apple's chips based on
arm architecture have good performance
too but are more power efficient so to
do this high performance i need less
power and i can just sip the watts
like a fine wine so you get it using its
own chips apple gets more performance
per watt or in other words it can have
the same battery size as a computer with
an intel chip but that battery can
theoretically last longer okay back to
computers and these actual tests
the old intel 16-inch macbook pro and
the new apple chip 16 inch macbook pro
both have the same 100 watt hour battery
take a look at this chart on my video
battery tests though the machines with
apple chips last at least five hours
longer on both streaming and local video
playback tests
about that 21 hours of battery life
apple's fine print says it got there
using a 16 inch test machine with an m1
pro processor a step down from the m1
max in my unit
plus there's more that's not even in
that fine print like turning off the
keyboard backlight and the true tone
display and the company said that the
white background in my video sample may
have drained extra juice
when i got an identical macbook pro with
the m1 pro chip adjusted all the
settings and used apple's recommended
test videos just 60 plus on itunes
guess what
21.5 hours but here's the thing video
rundown tests never tell the whole
battery story it's just not that
intensive of a processing task it's more
like stretching than jumping jacks plus
we all use our laptops differently so i
kept track of the battery life when i
used safari slack and played music in
apple music the 16-inch ran for eight
hours the 14-inch for six and a half
hours that was at least three hours
longer than apple's intel machines
when i did that test with chrome things
dropped by an hour or so nope not the
promised double-digit hours although
when i got out this bad boy
a 290 watt battery i was able to finally
hit those and yes i realize it's
basically just like being plugged into
the wall the 13-inch macbook pro with
the m1 chip announced last year actually
lasted just as long as those laptops in
my daily use
so i'll throw that back at you apple
when you say
and the longest battery life ever on a
mac notebook if you've got wi-fi off and
brightness at 50
and videos downloaded but please do not
confuse this with complaining after
years of slimming down laptops and
cramming in small batteries apple's got
a great strategy here power efficient
chips and big batteries
i just wish the fine print
was large print
how it's going to be for all apple
events now macbook pro now supports